and always asking me for a FaceTime you
want to
video call with him to FaceTime
so Ed said that he didn't hasn't spoken
to you at all and then now he's saying
he can't remember if he spoke to you I
didn't
that's not true
because he always messaged me and I have
a screenshot
okay well we we have that screenshot
this is what I wanted to read
oh gosh
can you read that for us please
um I hope all is well you looked amazing
she says thanks he says I want to come
to the Philippines again to see you if
you're open wow
you just said that you were in
communication with her Liz sit down
Jesus did he not just say that he he
hasn't spoken to her
did you say yes or no did you or did you
not just say I have not spoken to her
me no speak English
you know what it's not something to joke
about Ed it is because she's this is her
this is who Liz is please read the proof
is in the puddings he's reading the
stupid text tell me about that text just
tell me what about that text I've not
spoken to her see you just lied to
everybody right here
Liz what are you thinking right now
I um
tired of all lies
[Music]